[Music]
congratulations to everyone it's just
about 5:45 in the morning I just got my
n95 respirator all right I'm all suited
up ready to go up to people kids first
day of school with their lunch bag is
the first day that I was doctor
really I like actually did doctoring
things I think a lot of us were
definitely looking forward to these
months as months where we travel
celebrated graduation in person with our
families I didn't get to have last year
of medical school that I was expecting
because usually this is medical trainees
only time to have some time off to spend
time with their friends before we all
jump into our residences when I feel
proud that Hofstra graduated us early
and think that all of us have wanted to
do is to just go into the hospital and
lend a hand in any way that we possibly
can
I'm nervous about not living up to the
kind of heroism and helpfulness that
we're being talked about as there are a
lot of good reasons not to have chosen
to graduate early but for me there was
no choice I'm gonna be working today as
a recently deployed graduate physician
I'm a little bit nervous but I think
it's gonna be a great day she's gonna
help come up and witness the concept and
make sure I'm doing everything correctly
some of the challenges I experienced
today we're talking to Asians family
members and telling them at about
everything that was going on with their
with their loved one I think this is a
particularly humbling time to be a
doctor for me as a trainee who already
doesn't really know what to do
it feels like I'm extra unsure of the
care that I'm giving patients
all right done for the day heading home
in the hospital I'm learning quickly
over the course of this month how
difficult it is to do you have a
consenting talk I have to frame my talk
in a way that doesn't oversell or
undersell the therapy that we're
providing today I'm filming this one
from my car because my significant other
and I lived together and we both got
home from the hospital at the same time
and so really the only safe place for me
to kind of hang out until he's done
showering is my car we take off our
clothes that we bought in the hospital
let me put them in the hamper Here I am
talking to you now as someone who has
finished an entire week of being a
doctor and it was so nice walking around
today and New York in the spring is so
beautiful I was able to play some
basketball with my brother I was able to
play some board games with my brother
and my sister
I hope that I've been very helpful to
these patients that I've been able to
keep their families updated the whole
time I'm very grateful to all the people
that I've worked with on the clinical
trial who have taken time out of their
day to teach me the ins and outs and
what it takes to run a rigorous clinical
trial and it really has been incredible
to watch around me as every single team
has above and beyond risen to the
occasion and has put themselves last
finis for every three feet first it
really does feel like we're all living
through a moment in history I feel like
I'm reminded of that the most at 7 p.m.
every day when everyone the claps and
cheers that it feels like like a little
beacon of hope that we'll all get
through this
[Applause]
you